وقد توعد قائد الجيش السوداني ورئيس
المجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
باستخدام القوات المسلحه ما وصفه بالقوه
المميته اذا لم ينصع العدو لصوت العقل حسب
قوله
هذا وتعقد الاليه الموسعه بشان الازمه
السودانيه اجتماعها الاول في هذه الصبابه
اليوم وذلك بموجب قرار قمه مجلس السلم
والامن الافريقي التي عقدت السبت الماضي
ويهدف الاجتماع الى وضع خارطه طريق
للاتحاد الافريقي للازمه السودانيه
بمشاركه الشركاء الدوليين
وكشف مصدر دبلوماسي للجزيره ان احدى
وعشرين دوله الى جانب الاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمات الايجاد والجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده ستشارك
في الاجتماع اكد المصدر ان الاجتماع سيضع
اليات لتنسيق الدعم للسودان وتامين وقف
فوري ودائم وشامل وغير مشروط للاعمال
العدائيه فضلا عن وضع خارطه طريق تعمل على
تنسيق الجهود الاقليميه والقاريه والدوليه
لحل الازمه
معنى من عند المكتب الجزيره محمد طه توكل
اذا حول هذا الاجتماع المتوقع للجنه
الاتصال الدوليه ما سقف التوقعات
نعم الاستماع الان من خلف حيث اقف مقر
مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي كما تشاهدون
من خلف انطلقت الجلسه قبل خمسه دقيقه
وبدات المداولات فيما بينهم طبعا اهميه
التوقعات الموجوده اولا تم يتوقع ان
يتفقوا على الاليه
تدم للمره الاولى اليه دوليه لجنه الاتصال
الدولي تدم الامم المتحده والاتحاده
الافريقي وايجاد والجامعه العربيه ولا
زالت هناك جهود لادخال الاتحاد الاوروبي
لكن حتى الان لم يتوصلوا الى الاتفاق ربما
في نهايه الجلسه يحدد لكن تم الاتفاق على
اربعه منزمات
[موسيقى]
اقليميه وقاريه تتولى ملف السودان وتوحيد
الجهود الدوليه لانه تعدد المبادرات اجهد
كل المبادرات الجاريه ثانيا تم الاتفاق
على 21 دوله من ضمنهم
الدول العربيه يكونوا كمراقبين بجانب
الاليه
فواحد من اهم بنودها طبعا هذا بعدها بعد
شهر ونصف يتوصلوا الى اتفاق
لوضع عاليه وهذا كان قرار مجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي والان انطلقت الاجتماعات
ويتوقع ان يصدر قرار لحل الازمه السودانيه
طبعا ثلاثه بنود رئيسيه حسب مصادر
ابلغتنا يتم بحثها الا هي وقف اطلاق النار
فورا وارسال المساعدات والمرحله الثالثه
هي بداء العمليه السياسيه في السودان ولكن
سنتابع معكم بعد قليل ما يتمخد عن هذا
الاجتماع لكن يعتبر هذا الاجتماع هو الاهم
حتى هذه اللحظه الان سيكون قرار هذا
الاجتماع قرار الزامي بما انه مجلس الامن
الدولي ومجلس السلم الافريقي اشتركوا فيه
وايضا ثلاثه دوله افريقيه عدو عدويه غير
دائمه في مجلس الامن فبالتالي هذا
الاجتماع مهم يتوقع ان يصدر قرارت هامه
وايضا طبعا من الدول الحاضره عربيا هي قطر
وسعوديه والامارات بجانب طبعا سبعه دول
مجاوره للسودان تشارك في هذا الاجتماع
فهذا الاجتماع يعتبر مهم وتاريخي وخاصه
حتى هذه اللحظه وقفت اطلاق النار والهدن
تتراوح مكانتها والمعانات المدنيين تستمر
ويعتبر ازعاج كثير بالنسبه للقارة
الافريقيه يروا اكبر دوله افريقيه تواجه
عمليه التمزق ويتشرد ملايين من السودانيين
فبالتالي توقع اتخاذ قرار خلال الساعات
القادمه وسنتابع معاكم
من خلال ما يتمخد عن هذه الجلسه من هذه
السبب مدير مكتب الجزيره محمد توكل شكرا
جزيلا لك